welcome back everybody our next guest is
one of our favorites
her podcast is called sincerely fortune
with fortune feamster
it's available wherever you get your
podcast um and also make sure to check
out her website for her fall tour dates
please welcome fortune fam stars
[Music]
i love that they had you walk out to
like a slow jam that was cool
they know uh some sexy stuff is
happening
right now well you got married since i
got married
yeah thank you i was actually on your
show
like right before we got married and i i
was like kelly i'm getting married in a
couple weeks i love the color
look at that yeah we did a last minute
wedding where
we weren't really we didn't think we
were gonna be able to get married this
past year and with the pandemic because
we were gonna
have like a real thing and and then
in like september october we were just
like let's just
let's just get married like why are we
waiting yeah and so save your money and
buy something cool like a house i don't
know for real rather than a wedding yeah
so we planned in like three weeks
we had five friends get tested and we
kind of did an outdoor thing as you see
on the beach and
we we ended up zooming our families but
i didn't think about that in advance
because
you just don't think about you know
zooms and
weddings and so like 10 minutes before
the ceremony i'm like
oh like we should probably zoom our
families
and so i'm like frantically trying to
get a zoom link going and like
i don't know how the internet was down
and so you know we're like
sending it out we're like we hope we
remembered to send like
send it to everybody we forgot a few
people i think that you know
the it's a good pass the whole global
pandemic thing yeah it's a good it's a
good like
hey we tried we tried there's effort
yeah and i
i for sure saved a lot of money because
my family dude
we're southern we like to eat yeah that
would have bankrupted me
just about food and drinks if you're
something that's the food and drinks
my mom didn't like any of the fancy food
you got any sliders
sliders fried chicken i don't want this
ahi tuna um
but anyway so i noticed your um your
southern friend brenda
is really um you know enjoying her kelly
clarkson cup
kelly yeah brenda is a big fan of yours
and uh yeah she got the kelly clarkson
cup
and she takes it every time as she's in
the hot tub
she takes the dip hey y'all it's
me brenda i am
so happy right now uh i am in the hot
tub
taking a dip i got on my favorite
turquoise bathing suit and my favorite
visor i got my favorite cup over there
with my favorite talk show host kelly
clarkson
[Laughter]
love she loves it and so i i do this
character brenda and every time i post
a video as brenda and i have that kelly
clarkson
mug the swig cup in in my hand yeah i
swear to god i get like
200 messages from people being like
how do i buy that kelly clarkson mug
and i'm like so i'm like i'll let kelly
know
she should sell that as merch but we
should people
love that cup okay and uh yeah brenda is
a big
fan of your show she watches it all the
time is brenda also the one that was on
the black peloton looking back
that's deb that's damn it's like deb
had me rolling i was
crying i was laughing so hard what song
ride the train was it
and you were just going for it on that
bike so
i guess i was bored in quarantine i
created a lot of characters
and uh deb is a spin instructor who
actually never spins
she just sits on a she just either sits
at her desk or sits on a spin bank
and she goes come on everybody get on
your banks
and i did get on a bike that one time
and uh
tried to ride to come on ride that train
it's
my favorite thing you've ever done deb
got winded
deb was amazing your
outfit was upon point it was so great
it's a lot of spandex
[Laughter]
well you mentioned our cup um and soon
we will have our own swag store
um online we're still new we're just you
know i want to credit
brenda for that exactly
but in the meantime in honor of brenda
let's make the house seats happy so swig
is a fashion oriented drinkware brand
that offers a variety of insulated
tumblers
with designs that match current trends
and your own personal style
now everyone will get to have a wine
tumbler like brenda
because you're all getting a 200 swing
gift card
guys look at that
[Applause]
look what brenda is doing brenda is
changing lives
she's making ripples if y'all don't take
a dip in the hot tub with your swig cup
you'll miss them out and then go ride
your bike like
deb all right well i have something for
you as well because
this is the fifth time that you've been
on the show okay yeah
and usually we give you a team kelly
jacket for your fourth time but you
ambushed us last time and we missed it
so are back so we made it
i'm so sorry oh my god this is so
exciting oh yeah i spent the night in
your studio
okay see we made you a special
happy belated team kelly jacket this is
special no one has this one
oh my gosh no one has this one
[Music]
because you're special oh my god i'm
gonna sleep in this i gotta
it's soft actually yeah um i always you
know it sucks when you actually come up
with like merch from tour or something
or jacket like this and you love wearing
it because it's like soft and nice but
then you're like i can't wear this out
people are gonna i'm gonna look like a
douche like i'm walking around with my
name on it
i've worn
but if it's your own you're like oh i'm
just doing my team kelly and jackie
i wear my own ice cream merch you're
funny though i don't think i can pull
that off
i don't think i'm gonna start doing it
i'm going to beat that jelly
kelly all the way you're going to see me
in my team kelly jacket everywhere
all right well sincerely fortune with
fortune themed stores available wherever
you get your podcast
and check out fortune's website for her
fall tour dates yup i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help